welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and huge spoilers for doctor strange
of the multiverse of madness coming your
way because we have got to talk about
one of the biggest pieces of news to
come to the mcu in the form of the next
major threat looming on the horizon for
doctor strange and the rest of our
favorite heroes the multiversal
incursions like we've been telling you
this entire time
but what exactly did earth 838's most
well-read read mean when he talked about
that first incursion oopsie that led to
their doctor strange getting absolutely
torn apart during a very stern talking
to by one blackguard baltigo and why did
reid say that his doctor strange didn't
even tell him the details as to what
happened during this incursion was jim
halpert merely playing the prank as he
is apt to do oh jim halpert you in the
prank enough of the prank i am not
kidding or could this actually be marvel
studios laying the seeds to steven
strange's future as well as his dark
past well let's speculate on the
infinite multiverse of possibility of my
nerd babies because the multiverse is
definitely in trouble but before we
continue make sure to hit up
newrockstarsmirch.com to pick up our
latest obsession shirt inspired by dr
strange and the multiverse of madness
this new shirt has a really dope design
and it's not going to last forever so
make sure to hit up the website today to
check out all of our amazing merch
options at new rockstarsmerch.com all
right so about an hour into wanda being
extremely reasonable and not at all
frightening a very solemn read richard
states that his doctor strange the
doctor strange of earth 838 accidentally
destroyed the universe while
dreamwalking leading to a massively huge
event for the marvel comics known as the
incursions and it's exactly like reed
richard describes it in the movie the
early death of one universe disrupts the
balance of how the universe is arranged
causing the multiverse to basically
contract and get tighter together as a
response which in turn causes the
threads of two separate universes slash
timelines to collide together and if one
universe doesn't find a way to destroy
the other intruding universe then both
universes will die sort of like a dark
knight scenario with the boats which is
why the illuminati a team of the
smartest minds and most powerful forces
in the world chose to hid the fact that
they were destroying universes in secret
to preserve their own universe now if
this 838 strange was the one to actually
screw over the entire multiverse then
why didn't they just show us the
destruction of this universe in the
movie as opposed to having 838 strange
keep that secret to himself well i have
a feeling that this is because marvel
studios is trying to play the sneaky
sneaky everybody by trying to get us to
believe that this is just some poor
other random universe that we've never
seen before rather than the one that we
have already seen before say i don't
know in the last doctor strange film and
actually appears in the first
post-credits scene as the location clea
leads doctor strange into that's right
everybody i'm talking about the dark
dimension with dormammu himself being
that very same doctor strange dreamwalk
victim that 838 strange puppet
eventually leading to the annihilation
of his victim's entire reality but wait
a minute why would 838 illuminati
strange willingly destroy an entire
universe in the first place like wasn't
he a good guy trying to stop thanos in
his reality why the hell would
sacrificing an entire dimension to save
half of yours seem like something a
hippocratic oath taker would do because
doctor strange is a doctor and he had to
take the hippocratic oh and if 2022 is
the year you finally start your business
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence for
that business you want a website that
projects that you know what you're doing
and squarespace does just that
squarespace has a bunch of great
features to help your business be
successful you can present members only
gated content create email campaigns or
add online booking for appointments or
sessions all from squarespace's
interface and i really dig the analytics
section of a squarespace website where
you can just dig into what's working and
what you should be doing more of it's
catnip for numbers nerds so head on over
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com new rockstars to save 10
off your first purchase of a website or
domain that's squarespace.com new
rockstars for 10 off your first purchase
of a website or domain and thanks again
to squarespace for sponsoring this video
much like the ancient one and the rest
of the sorcerers of comataj used the
mirror dimension as a safe place to cast
spells this strange likely needed a safe
place to freely study the dangers of the
darkhold without fear of destroying his
own native universe in the process so to
do this he likely possessed another
doctor strange variant so that he could
be as reckless with that universe's dark
gold as he wanted practicing any and
every dark spell in the book to possibly
find a way to stop the mad type however
much like strange supreme and what if
doctor strange variants in the
multiverse tend to be incapable of
learning their lessons until after the
apocalypse which is as they say in
france too late
an illuminati strange would unleash a
spell that would ultimately flood his
victim's universe into complete darkness
turning that dimension into a dark
dimension and illuminati strange's
avatar into a hungry and greedy force
that wants to add more and more energy
into its big dark belly the size of the
universe because it literally is the
universe because again remember strange
supreme in how he spent years of his
life being addicted to absorbing the
energies of all of these mythical beings
into his own essence a lot like dormam
who wanted to absorb the energies of the
main mcu into his dark universe of
energy blobs illuminati strange was
either testing out the powers of the
darkhold in a safe space or even
potentially creating his own strange
supreme variant to be strong enough to
battle thanos however like reed richards
noted things got out of hand and this
newfound hunger might have gotten away
from the strange causing the entire
universe to become one with this new
insatiable dark being filling illuminati
strange with an indescribable amount of
guilt when he returned back to his
original body which is partly why he
willingly gave himself up to be
disintegrated by the king of the
inhumans he both had this knowledge of
this terrible universal calamity that he
just caused and that his corrupted
darkhold filled mind would likely
re-offend again because keep in mind
though he was dreamwalking illuminati
strange was the one who experienced
those events and how good it felt
possessing all of that dark power so
when he popped back into his body his
newfound addiction to darkness likely
came back with him which is likely a
sentiment shared by agatha harkness's
poor mother who had to kill her daughter
for her own darkhold corruption that
likely gave agatha that purple energy
draining power that we see sinister
strange using while telling our strange
to johann sebastian back off his library
books the darkhold seems to make you
hungry for more power which makes sense
because darkness absorbs light and i
believe that this hunger is what led
agatha to west view in the first place
because now that she had these new
energy absorbing powers she was going to
use them and have wanda's powers and
this is also sort of how wanda was able
to be captain maria in the film by
absorbing her tesseract energy until she
was just a regular squishable human
being but anyways as i alluded to before
this would make multiverse of madness's
post-credit scene make a whole lot of
sense as in the comic clea is the niece
of dormammu as dormammu's sister umar
will become clia's mother now if clia is
leading strange back to the dark
dimension after telling him that they
need to fix his incursion and we did get
the revelation of doctor strange's
sister donna in the multiverse of
madness and benedict cumberbatch being
the voice of dormammu in the first film
it seems to me that variant doctor
strange in donna will be the dormammu
and umar strange and clia have to face
off against in doctor strange three
because it all sort of adds up but yeah
that is what i think the first incursion
was it was dormammu and the dark
dimension like what do you guys think do
you guys think it was strange supreme
even though technically his universe is
still intact just really really small
that was the one who caused the first
incursion or do you guys think that
dormam who could actually be a doctor
strange variant let us know in the
comment section below but anyways thank
you guys so much for watching this video
you can follow me at mastertainment on
twitter but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
social media and when you do on youtube
make sure you hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video and again hit up
newrockstarsmerch.com so you can pick up
our newest latest obsession shirt it's
not gonna last forever and it's really
really cool looking but yeah thank you
guys again for watching this video i
love you guys so so so much and i'll see
you guys next time goodbye
[Music]
you